Finally, you get to program. Most of our exercises will be in JavaScript. Even
if you don't know JavaScript, you should be able to get through the first few
exercises without too much difficulty. Your goal in this exercise will be to
draw a square. To start with, you have to create a geometry object which allows
you to add vertices to it. Which let's you make triangles and squares and so on.
So, this geometry object will consist of vertices along with a face. Vertices
are the corners of a polygon, usually a triangle. Once we've created our
geometry object, we add vertices by pushing them onto the array. Basically, push
means add to the end of an array. And JavaScript keeps track of how large the
array is and so on, you don't have to worry about allocating space for it. And
these are our three vertices. We use Vector3 for both points and vectors within
3JS, within this library. So, these are floating point numbers in fact. And
define three points in x, y and z coordinates. A geometry object also has faces
in it. By using a Face3, we define three different vertices that we're going to
make a single face out of. In other words, we're going to define a triangle. The
way that face indices work is they point to the various vertices in the array.
So, this is vertex zero. We always start counting from zero. Vertex 1 and vertex
2, and by listing out those indices, 0, 1 and 2, so these are integers, that
says this triangle has this, this, and this vertex.